hey what is up guys mkbhd here and we
like to focus here on the highest end
flagship smartphones the best ones of
the top of the budgets that are really
pushing the boundaries of tech and
that's great but that also usually makes
us forget about the wave of awesome
smartphones that fills in that lower
budget in its wake they take awesome
tech from the higher end flagship
brothers and bring it down into that
lower price point one or two years later
so while it's nice to focus on those
high-end flagships for seven eight nine
hundred dollars because they're so
incredible it's also nice to take a look
at these sub 300
flagships that are taking those awesome
killer features and bringing them down
to the much more affordable level so
from my personal experience these are
the top five smartphones under 300 bucks
number five is the xiaomi me 4i at 250
this is one of the best looking best
designed budget smartphones out there
the cost will be inflated a little bit
by importing it but still for less than
300 bucks you get this slim sleek seven
and a half millimeter thick frame with a
soft touch back that actually reminds me
a lot of the nexus 5 and it's really
lightweight and easy to hold it's
rocking a pretty quality 5-inch 1080p
display and it has a quad-core
snapdragon 615 2 gigabytes of ram and
believe it or not a huge
3030 milliamp hour battery a lot of it
in and the design and the features it's
getting come from its older cousin the
xiaomi me note and it even has this
awesome adaptive display technology just
a really impressive phone to look at and
hold also that is a regular usb port on
the bottom even though it kind of looks
like usb-c this was definitely running a
heavier skin it's running something
called my ui 6 on top of android 5.0
lollipop it has these crazy wicked icons
it's very colorful there is no app
drawer it'll take a little bit of
getting used to but again it is a very
nice looking and very well designed
smartphone for the price point so number
four is the 2015 second generation moto
g at 180 this guy borrows a lot from the
flagship moto x but is designed
specifically to be low cost and it
delivers at a pretty ludicrously low
price it still manages to actually feel
pretty premium in the hands so it's well
built and you get features like the
stereo front-facing speakers and the
near stock android experience with a few
enhancements thanks to that moto x now
they couldn't bring moto maker down to
this level but you actually get a
removable back with this phone which
made room for swappable back covers of
different colors whenever you want and
they threw in a micro sd card slot for
expandable storage over the stock 8
gigabytes and the specs are pretty
alright too you will suffer with a
slightly subpar 720p display and a
pretty weak camera but i mean everything
else for the price you really can't go
wrong here oh and shout out to the even
cheaper moto e which brings back 4g and
subtracts 30 more dollars from the price
of the already awesome moto g so that
brings us to number three and it's
actually a relatively new phone that's
come out this year it's the alcatel one
touch idol 3 and it's 250 bucks the idol
burst onto the scene really a few weeks
ago and has quickly become a budget
favorite thanks to its big bright 5.5
inch 1080p display and great performance
it's pretty decent build too not too
tall for a 5.5 inch screen but also
pretty thin which is kind of nice and it
has a front facing speakers and a 2 910
milliamp hour battery not bad and
honestly it's a pretty fast phone too
it's rocking what initially looks like a
super skinned version of android but
it's really just an icon pack and then
some other smaller tweaks and it's been
one of the best performers on this list
it also has a 13 megapixel camera on the
back which is nothing too crazy in terms
of quality but it's definitely also
quite fast also a neat feature up its
sleeve since it is a completely
symmetrical phone on the front if for
some reason you want to flip the button
placement or something it has what's
called a reversible mode where it just
flips the entire ui upside down and
works exactly the same so the number two
best budget phone and it's actually
another one that just came out this year
for the first time is the asus zenfone 2
and it's 300 bucks this one was actually
first announced a while ago and most of
its hype came from being the first
smartphone with four gigabytes of ram
which is great but i haven't personally
noticed the difference versus three
gigabytes but i'll take it and this is
another budget phone that shines for its
build and its performance it has a
decent 5.5 inch 1080p display although
viewing angles i guess are a little bit
weak and then you get a quad core
processor 16 gigs of storage and a 3 000
milliamp hour battery and it's built
well with a matte brushed look on the
back and a pretty hefty weight to it
it's definitely not lightweight
and it has a removable back too so
revealing a dual sim card slot and you
guessed it a micro sd card slot asus
went uh with rear facing volume buttons
to keep the sides clean which i really
like they're not quite as tactile or as
big as lg's buttons but they're still
pretty good and then they for some
reason went with a power button in the
worst imaginable spot on a 2015
smartphone top middle i don't know who
decided to do this but you know at least
you get double tapping the screen to
wake and double tapping to sleep and the
software itself like i said works pretty
well it's a skin for sure on top of
android 5.0 lollipop and it has an intel
quad core chip inside that kept
everything moving pretty smoothly i
could game on this thing too you got
some some pre-loaded asus stuff but
overall pretty nice experience and
definitely feels in the hand like a lot
more than what you pay for it so the
number one best smartphone you can buy
on a budget under 300 bucks for the
second year running is the oh so popular
oneplus one it's gotten a permanent
price drop recently you can now buy it
without an invite system and it's now
exactly 300 this guy needs pretty much
no introduction i've done multiple other
videos about this phone it's just a
freak basically it has a quality 5.5
inch 1080p display a fast quad-core
snapdragon 801 chip three gigabytes of
ram a huge 3100 milliamp hour battery
with a pretty ridiculous like
industry-leading battery life and
awesome performance from its choice of
roms based on stock android and the
phone itself is built pretty well too it
feels great in the hand the unique
texture of the sandstone black version
is pretty interesting it's not too huge
for a 5.5 inch phone there's a reason
why this guy won best budget smartphone
for 2014 from me last year this thing is
legit the oneplus one also has a 13
megapixel camera that's really good and
that's a nice bonus because usually when
you go down in price you really start to
sacrifice on the camera so this actually
has a nice camera that sort of competes
with at least in the image quality
department some of the other much higher
end flagships that's basically it it's
the oneplus one and it's it's kind of
funny because it's not really built off
of another high-end flagship where it
gets its features from it is its own
flagship which is pretty awesome for the
price so there you have it those are the
best smartphones you can get at a low
budget in 2015 right now uh also i want
to give an honorable mention to first of
all the sony xperia m2 which is cut from
the same cloth as the sony xperia z
flagships so you get that waterproofing
at a low budget also the microsoft lumia
640 which is hands down the best cheap
windows phone and has an awesome display
and a pretty decent battery life and
also the sharp aquas crystal which i did
an entire video about it's the best
designed budget smartphone by far i'll
leave a link to that along with all the
other smartphones i've talked about
right below that like button if you want
to check any of them out uh and yeah
that's basically it so moral of the
story here is a lot of the smartphones
that we can get for 300 today
rival the experience you get from the
phones we would have spent six or seven
hundred dollars on three or four years
ago so that's something to be pretty
happy about thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys the next one peace
you